i think that's what 85 south is all
about is you guys doing it your way
let's see the 85 south show is us saying
oh y'all don't want to [ __ ] with it all
right we'll [ __ ] with it we'll do it
ourselves
yeah because we know that we we interact
we on the road we know what people want
we know what they need
this ain't that even if they put if you
put us on your network your tv show
they still need this you get what i'm
saying this is the part that they [ __ ]
with because they seen us
come up and rise as comedians and be on
television and be on different shows and
add those notches and you know stripes
to our comedic
accolades so they know what the rise is
they sing dc on instagram
and vine and all that they know that the
grind pays
off and you get to get bigger and bigger
and bigger
but at some point they're like but what
you doing
we see you every night on csi but what
you doing though
what you know i'm saying what you
talking about we know that you ain't
getting to say the [ __ ] that you want to
say so what are you what do you have to
say
it don't have to be a [ __ ] 5d
hd red camera now i want to see that
camera phone
[ __ ] somebody record that they smoking a
blunt what they talking about
i guess that [ __ ] that you can't get
nowhere else it's all that authenticity
right because that's what makes people
[ __ ] with you
they need to see that you're a real
[ __ ] like you like them
uh-huh it's the realness how real what
type of blunts this [ __ ] smoking is
that good is that all right
so everybody connects with you for
different [ __ ]
you might make a fan cause you did that
one clean joke
or that one [ __ ] joke made that old man
buy that ticket to see you again
or these white dudes who who was
tripping on some mushrooms one night and
watched your [ __ ] for 12 hours straight
now they really [ __ ] with you like you
you know what i'm saying yeah you never
know
how people get attracted to you or what
makes people buy
tickets to come see you specifically or
it's pee digging inviting you up to the
office
it could just small stuff like that you
never know who's sitting back watching
these episodes man
it's crazy man yeah diddy been watching
the [ __ ] from 40 episodes it was on the
trap house he liked the trap
he liked the trap house episode bruh it
was like man how long you been watching
this [ __ ]
and what episode made you say all right
man call them [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] moment was that
because i want to know that moment
so i can have some more of them [ __ ] did
you ask him hell yeah
what'd he say yeah i asked him man i
asked daddy all types of [ __ ]
what'd you learn from him i learned that
this dude
has a wide scope you know like the big
fish in that [ __ ] this dude has a wide
scope of everything that's going on not
because somebody said hey dude check
this out
because he actually physically gets in
that [ __ ] and
and listen and goes on to youtube and
and finds the new [ __ ]
and vibe with that [ __ ] like a real fan
he's still a fan of everything
he's very aware of who he is and he he
understands the game and what's
what's going to be the the game changes
before they're even the game he's like
he can see that [ __ ] that is
very inkling you know like that's the
[ __ ] that changed the game
and he'd be passionate about this [ __ ]
like his real [ __ ] already
you know what i'm saying that's what i
picked up that's the vibe that and it's
really
not just like we're so used to seeing
diddy the
you know the character but then you
sitting there like this is a real ass
dude like you know what i'm saying like
you would never know that he's not
yelling
pouring sorak everywhere you would think
that
and that's what you would want to happen
if you think that that [ __ ] is funny now
until you wouldn't
that's why i was like bro we got to
drink some soraka with daddy yeah
you said that in the video yeah but you
would definitely like if he came out and
he was doing that [ __ ] if it was a big
daddy production
and he came out with you would be like
yeah [ __ ] yeah
he didn't disappoint me i knew he was
this [ __ ]
but then he come out and then sean john
hey what's up guys you know
yeah this is whatever tc like that type
is like oh man you never know which
diddy's gonna show up yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so sean john showed up bro we got to
speak to sean john
diddy p diddy i asked him if i could
still call him puffy he told me it was
cool
because that was like all the rap [ __ ]
the old rap [ __ ] that i came up with
like
big smiles and like missy used to throw
puffy name in a lot of her songs oh yeah
she had the famous line puff daddy be my
pal and she said that in like seven
songs bro
i always wondered why was nikki i mean
why was missy
and diddy such good friends i never saw
the connection
but she threw that in a lot of songs bro
yeah man i had a ball he's i asked him
about that infamous line what he said
i got a benz that i ain't even drove yet
he said he still ain't drove it
are you just kidding me i'm not bro he
said he still ain't drove it man
serious business that's game right there
that's bruh that is crazy
yeah what on the actual
why did he hit you guys up like what was
the reason
he loves this show bro he loves the show
he really want to work with you like
yeah he really [ __ ] with what we got
going on
he sees that we build an organic
following
and we're giving them raw real content
every look
different looks you know what i'm saying
and he just sees that we could really do
something big
with what we have from what he's telling
you
like he have a vision just thinking of
it being on revolt or even just trying
to be like this is what the potential
could be even it was just even bigger
than that he was like
even if it's not revolt i just know that
this is
this is the new [ __ ] this is a wave in
comedy
not because not just saying that this is
comedy this is a different
this is a different perspective that
we're not getting nowhere else and like
it's it's not super flashy rapper
it's not bling-bling in your face it's
the
it's the joys the pains the ups and
downs the the grind of
chasing the entertainment dream you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
you guys are actually capturing that
right in the meantime
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips